Thanks Ryan.
For exploratory analysis like these plots, we can clearly see patterns or
deviations in the data that we might miss from a table or summary statistics.
But there's still an even more important reason for
creating graphics like these in the first place.
The key lies in the immense power of our visual processing system.
Danish physicist Tor Norretrander converted the bandwidth of
our senses to computer terms to help us understand this power.
In this visualization,
I can see that sight takes up the majority of the frame here.
In fact, it's been said that sight can process information up to the speed of
computer networks, or an Ethernet cable.
Sense of taste has the bandwidth of a calculator.
And the small white box at the corner of this frame is only 0.7% of the area,
and it's what we are aware of when all this processing is happening.